i did i'm one of those guys who's doing
a re-watch podcast me too okay it
started uh wednesday called talkville
it's about re-watch smallville i'm doing
one with tim simons called second in
command which will we did the first half
we'll be coming back soon enough spite
that has caused me
to go through every episode of veep and
i'm like oh i did a good job i like that
real performance yeah i don't hate it
like i know and i and i also can watch
everything like i can watch other people
and like because i think as an actor
sometimes you're myopic and you're like
i got to get this monologue writer i got
to get the scene writer i got to get
like you know what i mean so you're
you're a little
just focused on your scene and then you
see this beautiful show
when it's all packaged together and you
can really enjoy it as a fan like i'm
sure you can watch
the whole show now
and not just see yourself but like oh my
god yes he was great she was great yeah
and not that you didn't appreciate other
people before but i think we're
burdened with our nervousness to
deliver
and some of that comes from insecurity
some of that comes from ego
some of that is just like it's human
beings trying to do a good job and
everybody has that right so it's
refreshing to go like five years after
whatever the last episode of vp was out
to go back through the first i think
we've gone through the first three and
watch them and not feel
anything but like wow that's a great
show that was really good and and to
also
literally be removed and watch it as a
fan is amazing will you have guests on
that show yes we do we try to get every
week we'll try to get
anybody that who came through the show
one of the regulars tony's been on
julia's been on
sam's been on is that a lot of fun to go
back it is
it is did they actually go back and
watch or they you don't no we don't
watch we just start to have talking
points and we'll hit the plot and then
we'll just go anywhere subject matter
can go anywhere we just have it be a
conversation you ever been intimidated
by someone you're working with
yeah
i'm trying to think like any big actor
came on set and you're like oh [ __ ]
these are big pointed questions um
names names names and names
intimidated well i think hugh laurie
coming into veep was a big moment for me
i was intimidated by him because he's a
consummate amazing
dramatic comedic guy yeah
uh there was also a director on v name
chris morris i don't know if you know
him no he directed these really
subversive shows called the brass eye
and he was sort of uh
i was way
uh intimidated by him because he has
this very aggressive almost like sasha
baron cone prank style comedy that was
an early
probably influenced sasha and a lot of
stuff that happened over here so he was
just someone i was intimidated by those
are two names that come to mind
you